rien il était candidat il ya trois
saisons c'est ça ouais et il m'avait
impressionné je trouvais était déjà très
mature pour son âge
excellent magicien et comme j'ai trouvé
très gelé blessé à la main vous verrez
qu'il est un plâtre maintenant parce que
je ne voulais pas de concurrence là-bas
bras et donc maintenant on va voir s'il
arrive quand même à faire la magie
blessés et là j'y arrive maintenant tu
as quel âge moyen haut niveau maintenant
17 tu peux rentrer tous
[Applaudissements]
non
tu as dit cet homme aux yeux revolvers
un petit tour pour les téléspectateurs
alors regardez bien parce que il est
très très fort ils mettent à 17 ans un
plâtre il est certifié phare eric
antoine
il se passionne dans la part le bec
digne de parcours ce montois que ça je
peux commencer mon temps et je crois que
je venu pour discuter quoi donc
on cherchait sur une carte on peut et
jean-michel on peut jean-michel une
carte toit basse bon le temps de
quelqu'un d'autre
[Rires]
si tu me dis ce que tu veux d'accord
battant on va en faire voir ici par un
cavani non ici 10 de carreaux tu vas
changer très bien qu'elle regarde je
déchire et le coin
ouais t'as du conflit sans merci à la
couleur
quel acteur ses rôles ça m'énerve côté
saison
[Applaudissements]
ça va énerver ses réusltats regarde vous
arrêtez pas des navettes sont bonne
humeur
je suis fais là ils permettent la peau
car voilà la halle a complètement
disparu la carte à la bouille la quinte
ou quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai pas dit c'est que en fait un
magicien ça se fait jamais mal en fait
le bandage ce n'est qu'une diversion
depuis le début j'en étais sûr regarde
moi j'ai vu parce que je suis optimiste
mais qu est ce qu est ce que tu peux
enlever le scotch soda petit épilation
gratuit c'est le dise
et